what's happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba
no I'm John old we were gonna watch
today from Jean jetter Jeter Jeter I
think that's right I remember yes your
check out his Instagram page he's a
photographer a lot of very just
unattractive woman he is constantly
photographing and very heavyset men very
anyway he has a YouTube page as well
ready post a lot of short films and is
there a third one we're checking out
from him Godfather run ooh here's a
description says there are two sides to
every issue one side is right and the
other is wrong but the middle is always
evil okay see one of our top of war
tears on patreon is whatever video you
requested was definitely doing put up on
the youtubes let's do this there are two
sides to every issue one side is right
and the others are the middle is always
evil and I feel like I read that
somewhere I don't know if I agree with
that I Rand on that big old Fountainhead
guy this was like my backyard
love that back backmasking like this
painting cats mm-hmm
air walk interesting
I'm curious this whole thing in Reverse
look at all the paint on his pants I
think he stole some money she runs
things she's upstairs
feel like Jean and Nicolas when the ref
you would get along
oh yeah all your next short needs is a
really thick sit score well little weird
ass looking effect just through a window
maybe look so or is that it I mean I
like this sort of voyeuristic quality
that this house did she hit another one
of his short-films
um is on the left here yeah is she from
the one with the art installation their
structure
otherworldly yeah it is he was in the
first one yeah he works with the same
actor she's got a trip you like
Christopher Guest and a shirt like that
I borrowed it and never returned
extras
production value
[Music]
[Music]
he's the boyfriend right double bag Hey
yeah
I think it's a guy thing shrimp buzz
that makes it
and you Jason what these - Jason is his
friend Chris Chris is just always need
financial problems Jason always wants to
help but like weird like improvements or
something I mean group together so I
decide to stare but
I'm actually at the party then trying to
reach you having done touch with you all
day for some reason I need that money
that I'd let you write the way I got it
from you know what that means thanks for
explaining it I did not know what that
to borrow money from Minji I told him he
doesn't listen
stupid
huh oh damn
I just need more time I'll get your
money
I love money please I just need some
more time that's all I need
[Music]
[ __ ] look [ __ ] the money wasn't for
me it was for my friend I gave it to him
he tells me he's the Godfather here on
the dot father and matches the baby then
things get worse
Jeanne's James
I'm rocking a hard place now
damn it's not law it's time to get a
baby
well John once that is right and the
other is wrong middle it's always easy
coming up I like this girl game yeah
it's called a gang these days
what happened to Chris the wife the baby
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
going an ties house
[Music]
terminating our eyes was the mascot it's
just that red vision
[Music]
now I had
I like you the surreal noise music
how's he gonna cry damn its name in the
movie I get it now that was cool man
honestly I think that's the best one
we've seen so far that you've provided
here I think you have an interesting way
of structuring your storytelling you do
seem like you are a novelist at heart
you do a lot of things with people
talking to the cameras explaining the
plot and everything like that
I like the Asian actress here who's the
leader I like your ideas a lot and the
storytelling structuring things are very
interesting and a little skip back and
ding you did with the audio with the
music I always thought was really cool
yeah I like your instincts for the
structures and stuff like that I'm often
a little confused at times a little bit
wondering what's going on but I think
you'd kind of like that abstract quality
that you sort of provide I really feel
like you're a novelist you know oh yeah
yeah and I mean I know you're a
photographer too so like every short of
yours I've watched has come with a
certain element of either surreal nasur
or just sort of out of the box miss for
me yeah yeah I never feel like you're
just trying to make just a
straightforward linear short film you
know and I appreciate that I do
appreciate like some of the framing
devices that you bring in with the black
and white versus color and having you
know this girl talking to the camera for
some of it I wasn't exactly sure when we
cut to the two girls on the bench what
that was about but no dude I totally got
that they were playing death death with
a cell phone perfect but I like some of
the might just be too hot woman he was
photographing and he said it won't be my
short film I mean it doesn't seem like
Jean knows a lot of people a lot of
those people are generally I liked the
kind of array of different characters
and stuff like that what kind of camera
is shoot on Jean because this kind of
this old-school vibe to it you know what
I think I would like a little bit more
from your short films if I'm being
honest as I've seen your Instagram page
you know how to do photography I think
if you could just do a little bit more
detailed work on the exposure of things
like the the way you do the
cinematography
I feel like you'll lend yourself to
something that amps it up with a little
bit more stylish choices in terms of the
framing because you clearly have style I
mean like you were talking about the
different framing devices to help around
to the different colors even in the very
end when the guys talking themself in
the mirrors the handheld shot you have
all these intent and choices and dings
yeah exactly but I think it would be
cool if you did just hone in a little
bit more on some lighting capabilities
as well because I feel like a lot of
this could lend itself to some really
interesting hardcore striking visual
imagery but right now in terms of your
structure and what you go for in your
writing I find it very interesting
different for sure very appealing so
yeah keep it up I would agree with that
I mean yeah maybe maybe finesse some of
you and I think this is an older short
perhaps than some of the other ones
we've checked out but I would say add a
little more finesse to to your exposures
and whatnot and smooth the sound over
because I think the sound will help yeah
you can get even just like a basic mic
or something like that because I don't
know exactly what your resources are or
what it's like when you go out and shoot
one of these like I kind of get the
sense that it's probably just you and
your actors and stuff like that and you
know we've worked like that a lot as
well and yeah it's just a little more
smoothing out of those visual elements
and then if you're doing a more linear
plot like this maybe to avoid certain
moments like the direct exposition of
life you know when somebody says you
know what this means
I always kind of appreciate it when the
sentence stops there and then we find
out in some other way rather than just
having it be it means this you know so
in the future I would personally smooth
out things like that but yeah like novel
aside yeah I know I know I gotta you
gotta find that middle ground see the JK
Rowling
yes yourself I mean I don't want to go
against Iron R and here but I will I
would I would say that I feel like a lot
of people make heist short films like
this and I like that you brought a
different style to it you know why I
think as my favorite part of this is
just sort of your stylistic instincts
you know so keep it up gene thanks for
being here buddy
and send us another one might as well
write
subscribe I